so a bunch of redditors on wall street
bets found out that a hedge fund was
short in gamestop so they thought it'd
be fun to raise the price
in the process they may have destroyed
the financial markets as we know them
then the hedge fund says that the
redditors are manipulating the market
the redditors say that the hedge fund is
manipulating the market and then robin
hood says that no one can even trade and
everyone loses a ton of money
and everyone's gonna end up suing each
other but hans
bobby i'm your white knight i must have
missed
60 minutes and i'm here to explain what
in the world
is going on with gamestop reddit
robinhood and the entire stock market
and whether any of this is legal
[Music]
sponsored by ting mobile hey legal
eagles it's time to think like
a securities lawyer because trading on
the stock market is booming right now
according to online brokerages there's
been a huge increase in trading activity
during the pandemic and in particular
a ton of people have been hanging out on
the subreddit forum
wall street bets where they discuss
stock tips information
while also making fun stock memes
basically
and part and parcel to that many people
have signed up with the trading app and
brokerage known as robinhood which says
it's on quote a mission to democratize
finance for all now ramahood is
particularly interesting because
unlike most brokerages they encourage or
at least allow
a huge number of people to trade on
margin or
to access options trading which as we'll
talk about in a few minutes is
sort of like giving dynamite to children
now of course
uh that might cause a huge amount of
damage but it's definitely going to be
fun to watch
and speaking of which there are a lot of
gamers on reddit and they've taken an
active interest in a retail video game
shop known
as gamestop there are still 5 000
gamestop stores
around america but there's also some
reason to think that gamestop
is going to struggle in the near future
it faces challenges like
closing malls and competition from
illegal downloads and also legal
downloads since
a lot of people are downloading games
instead of purchasing the physical
copies in brick and mortar stores
the company doesn't expect to turn a
profit until 2023
some people think gamestop may even
disappear just like blockbuster
but not everyone agrees that gamestop is
on their last legs and the people of
reddit have been talking about gamestop
as a good company for a couple of years
then some big time investors announced
that they had invested in gamestop
including the co-founder of the online
pet store chewie
this made some investors take notice and
redditors realized that
many investors had taken a short
position on gamestop
the people of this subreddit decided
that if they acted in concert to drive
up the price of the stock
they could actually make a good profit
by squeezing people who had shorted the
gamestop
stock man try saying that a couple times
fast
but just a few days ago there were 1.9
million members of wall street bets
now it's up to four maybe five million
members of wall street bets
so if a substantial percentage of those
people bought gamestop
then they really could have an impact on
the stock
and that is exactly what we saw happen
in january redditors got to work buying
up gamestop
stock gamestop's stock price
was trading at under 20 at the beginning
of the year
but by january 27th it had soared to 350
dollars
now the financial industry is up in arms
the sec is watching
redditors are pushing up the price of
several other stocks including amc
elon musk and the winklevi twins are
cheering them on
and so there is a bit of a david and
goliath framing in this whole war
especially if you're reading reddit
the redditor investors are saying that
they're doing just what regular folks do
when they invest in the markets trying
to bet on stock prices on the rise so
although the traditional investor
community is somewhat aghast at all this
activity
one could argue that the little guys and
gals are just trying to do what the
wealthier people have been doing for
years hoping to make money from a
company's growth
though the giant hedge funds many of
whom drive the short stock positions are
pretty mad about this and they are of
course the enemy of the people
or at least that's according to reddit
but before we grandstand too much
further down the
victor hugo track keep in mind that
there are lots of institutional
investors like these hedge funds
like pension funds endowments and credit
unions who may suffer also huge losses
because of what these redditors are
doing with gamestop
and the reverberations that are going
through the entire stock market
which takes us to the crux of what's
going on here because you can't
understand the game stop
controversy without understanding the
mechanics of the trades that are going
on
the question is who is getting hurt by
traders trying to inflate the stock
price
well it's the people who took a short
position on gamestop and here's a quick
explanation of what that means to short
a stock
people obviously invest in the stock
market to make money and most small
investors try to buy a stock that has
not yet reached its full potential
making the bet that something will
happen to increase the value of that
stock or security
but investors can also bet against a
company's future potential this is
called shorting a stock shorting a stock
enables an investor to actually make
money when the stock goes down because
you can't make money by buying a stock
hoping it goes down because then the
value of the thing that you
purchased has gone down for an investor
to shorter stock
they actually have to borrow the stock
from someone else the investor does this
by opening a margin account which lets
them borrow
the stock itself the short seller wants
to see that the stock's price will fall
in the future allowing the short seller
to buy the stock back
at an even lower price and pocketing the
difference
but this is a riskier position than
simply buying a stock with the hope that
the value goes up
when you buy a stock at let's say 20 the
most you can lose is the amount you paid
20 and that will only happen if the
stock you bought goes to zero
but shorting a stock is dangerous
because at some point you must
buy back the stock that you borrowed so
if you're shorting the stock you
borrow the stock at let's say 20 and it
skyrockets to 500
you're in a world of hurt if the value
of the stock goes up there's no limit to
how much you might lose
the downside risk is literally infinite
you might have to buy it back at a huge
loss in our example
the short seller is squeezed they need
to pony up 500
on an initial investment of only 20 so
you can do the math i'm in danger so
this appears to be what happened with
the reddit day traders versus the
institutional investors who took a short
position on gamestop
a lot of the people on reddit just
simply like gamestop
as a company so they wanted to build up
the price and if they could
destroy a hedge fund at the same time so
much the better and at some point
redditors on wall street bets realized
that more people were shorting the stock
than actually owned it in fact
140 of the float a lot of people think
that this is illegal
it's not this is a relatively normal
thing and hedge fund melvin capital was
one of the hedge funds who was on the
other end of the trade
we know by now that melvin capital has
closed out its short position which
means that
they had to buy all the stock that they
were shorting at a much much
higher price no one's been able to
exactly confirm how much they lost
but we do know that citadel and .72
bigger hedge funds have infused close to
three billion dollars to melvin capital
to shore up its finances and
melvin capital only had roughly 12
billion dollars to start
and this has fueled speculation that
melvin capital might have gone bankrupt
if not for the cash
infusion but that's where things got
even crazier with the price of the
gamestop stock
fluctuating wildly going up thousands of
percent
in the middle of all of this robin hood
the preferred brokerage and trading app
of the people on wall street bets
decided to stop
all trading on gamestop on january 28th
and some have reported that as many as
half of the people that use the robin
hood app
in general had some sort of position on
gamestop and some have reported that
after robin hood
stopped all trading on uh gamestop they
allowed some people to exit their
positions but not buy back in
and also some report that robin hood was
actually closing their positions and
selling other options or stock
in either gamestop or amc causing
fury among the people that were trying
to hold on to the stock forever
so with that admittedly superficial
explanation of the facts here
now we get to the legal questions is any
of this illegal
is it illegal for a bunch of people on
the internet
if not to band together then at least
express what they're going to do in the
hopes that they
drive prices in a certain direction does
the sec
care about that is it illegal for robin
hood to
prevent people from trading in the way
that they want is that something that
can give rise to a clash action lawsuit
and of course the initial action that
gave rise to all of this
is it legal for the hedge funds to have
a massive short position
and try and drive the market and the
answer
as with most things is it depends so
let's first talk about
market manipulation as you probably know
securities fraud is
illegal some common types of security
fraud include manipulating stock prices
lying on
sec filings and committing accounting
fraud but fraud also includes activity
that manipulates the market
so what do we mean by market
manipulation and why does it matter
market manipulation tends to distort the
prices of stocks and securities which
damages the market's integrity because
the conduct can lead to other market
participants to believe that the market
is rigged or unfair and of course it
actually changes the prices that people
pay for these things
because our economy is rigged and after
the financial meltdown
of 2007 2008 that belief was
obviously somewhat justified and many
people lost their homes and life savings
while
giant financial institutions got bailed
out after
going effectively bankrupt now after the
financial crisis congress passed the
commodity exchange act as a method of
combating fraud in financial markets
congress added the cea section 6c which
prohibits manipulative and deceptive
devices and contrivances
and adopted a rule which prohibits any
manipulative device
scheme or artifice to defraud now market
manipulation has been illegal
for a very long time i believe it was in
place in the original
securities and exchange act of 1934
under rule 9
but i'm going to focus on the cea
definition of market manipulation
because it's both more recent and
seems to have a reasonably clear test
now whether there is market manipulation
under the cea is decided by a four-part
test
that the accused had the ability to
influence market prices two
that the accused specifically intended
to create or affect a price or price
trend
that does not reflect legitimate forces
of supply and demand
three that the artificial prices exist
and four that the accused caused the
artificial prices
so the first question did redditors have
the ability to influence market prices
well it seems clear after a few days of
this that
the answer is obviously yes they
succeeded in dramatically raising the
price's stock
now did they intend to inflate the
gamestop stock in a way that was
illegitimate and did not reflect the
forces of supply and demand
well obviously you can argue it both
ways now on the one hand this might be
an example of classic market
manipulation known as a pump and dump
scheme
but it doesn't really fit exactly in
that milieu
in a classic pump and dump scheme
fraudsters talk up stocks claiming that
they have inside information about
something that will cause the stock's
value to skyrocket
this inside information is actually just
nonsense and the goal is to entice
buyers to quickly buy up penny stocks
and after the buyers jump in the
fraudsters sell their own shares making
a big profit
but causing the price to drop
dramatically of course
the new buyers are left holding their
hat and lose their money
this used to happen through cold calls
but in the modern era chat rooms and
forums have been fertile grounds for
fraudsters
illegally giving false information in
the hope of driving up a stock price so
that they can
sell for much less pump and dump schemes
are clearly illegal under several laws
such as the securities act of 1933
the securities and exchange act of 1934
and 18 usc
section 371 at sec now if this activity
does fall under the rubric of market
manipulation
it would qualify as what scholars call
open market manipulation
because this isn't happening behind
closed doors this isn't happening
because of a cold call
it's happening in plain sight it's
happening on the internet and everyone
effectively
has access to this information and the
sec argues that market manipulation can
in fact happen through social media
one way fraudsters may exploit social
media is to engage in market
manipulation such as spreading false and
misleading information about a company
to affect
that stock's share price wrongdoers may
perpetrate stock rumors on social media
as well as on online bulletin boards
and internet chat rooms the false or
misleading rumors may be positive or
negative
and the subreddit wall street bets
really seem to be exploiting social
media to spur
interest in lifting the game stop stock
price in order to manipulate the market
four months ago a post appeared on wall
street bets with a subject bankrupting
institutional investors for dummies
featuring gamestop there's been a
perception that the traders of reddit
are just internet trolls out for a
joyride and the title of the post
certainly reinforces that perception
you could also interpret this post as
evidence that the redditors wanted to
manipulate the market for gamestop stock
in an illegal way to hurt big investors
who shorted the stock
on the other hand there's not much
evidence that the posters who used wall
street bets were lying about gamestop or
creating false rumors designed to pump
up the stock's value so they could
induce people to buy the stock
wall street bets also has a counter
argument that there's evidence that
redditors were being thoughtful about
their position not
intending to screw people over the post
isn't just about bankrupting short
sellers it lays out many reasons to
believe that gamestop will make it as a
going concern quote
well it turns out their books are rock
solid they offered their creditors a new
set of terms to push back debt for two
years
fifty percent of them took it they have
eliminated all excess goodwill
impairments they're in a 300 million net
cash position with significantly reduced
inventory which explains the sharp
reductions in q1 to
sales and massively cut sg a by 28
in preparation for the console cycle and
of course many things can be true at
once especially when you're dealing with
a group of potentially thousands of
people who all have different
motivations for what they're doing
some traders shared apparently
legitimate information about gamestop
and talked about it their arguments
appeared to be convincing to lots of
other traders
they have a free speech right to make
these statements so
was that market manipulation well we
have to talk about intent because
the sec and other enforcement agencies
argue that even legitimate transactions
are manipulative
if the trader intends to manipulate the
market the government's position is that
an investor's intent is enough to turn a
legitimate transaction
into illegal market manipulation and
anyone who's watched this channel before
at all knows that the same actual
conduct
can become illegal based on the men's
ray of the mental state that you have
when you conduct that action and of
course the traders of reddit seem to
have
a mixed motive and there are lots of
different people acting for many
different reasons
on the other hand there's almost no
argument that this isn't a really
weird and interesting case in part
because you generally don't have the
telltale signs of securities fraud
this is not the classic case where
someone is talking up stock
getting other people to buy so that they
can sell at a higher price themselves
really while there are exceptions to
this it seems that most of the things
that people are talking about on reddit
are true they are not false they are
talking about real things
in the world as well as what they intend
to do they're trying to get the entire
internet to buy the stock
hold it drive up the price screw over
the hedge funds who are shorting it
and potentially save a company that a
lot of people have fond memories over
though granted fraud is not required for
market manipulation under the sec's
definition so
just because people have good motives
doesn't mean that their intent doesn't
qualify
as illegal market manipulation and at
the same time
anytime you have a whole bunch of people
coordinating to
change the price of something you have
to ask the question
is that an antitrust violation because
the sherman anti-trust act section one
deals with
setting market prices and that applies
to even individuals it doesn't
just require that monopolies and cartels
are the ones that can't set market
prices
when you engage in a conspiracy to set a
price you
might be engaged in something illegal
under the sherman nanny trust act
but let's talk about who's manipulating
whom here because one reason there's so
much fury over this situation is that
people feel like
markets are nothing but a fake game
anyway and there's certainly a kernel of
truth to this since
everyone that participates in the market
changes prices by their very
participation
in the market itself and that changes
the prices of stocks and securities to
some small degree but of course the
market is regulated and in other words
there are laws that can strain traders
from crossing certain lines
and the reddit investors claim that the
hedge funds get to do whatever they want
to manipulate the markets crossing
every line that retail investors don't
get to cross and are getting punished
because
of trying to use the same tools that the
hedge funds have been using for years
and a lot of people would absolutely
argue that this is a question of
under enforcement of the sec's rules
rather than over enforcement that
there's nothing that would exempt the
hedge funds from the
exact same rules as everybody else it's
just a question of the sec's resources
the sec has been classically underfunded
and there's no doubt that the actual
definition is codified in the law of
market manipulation is incredibly broad
it's another question entirely whether
all of the activity that falls under
that definition should be considered
illegal or not
but there's nothing that would exempt
the hedge funds from
being punished under those same rules if
the sec decided to
make that a priority but that being said
there is no validity to the idea that
short selling alone
is an illegal practice even if someone
you don't like is doing it
short selling has existed for hundreds
of years basically as long as there has
been
stock markets short squeezes have
existed gamma traps have existed
all of these are just tools and in and
of themselves
don't qualify as market manipulation but
that being said since we're talking
about the hedge funds
let's talk about the allegations of
collusion between
robin hood and the hedge funds
themselves many have speculated
some with more evidence than others that
robin hood
agreed to stop trading on the gamestop
stock
specifically as a concession to
hedge funds that it does business with
in one way or
another and these allegations seem like
more conspiracy theories than they are
based
in real life that being said it is also
possible if not more probable
that these actions are related to
legitimate business concerns rather than
a conspiracy to defraud robin robinhood
customers
for example most people are trading on
margin which means that they're not
actually purchasing individual stocks so
much as getting the right to purchase
the stocks
from robinhood and the market makers
that robin hood interacts with
and because of that a lot of these
transactions don't clear for
many days after they're put in place
these are incredibly complicated
transactions that involve a number of
different companies and
in this instance robin number one was
probably worried about its own liquidity
given the incredible volatility going on
to be able to fulfill these orders
number two it was probably worried about
the
counterparty risk of the companies that
it was dealing with to make the markets
and fulfill these orders and
number three was probably worried about
the actual ability of its customers who
are trading on
extreme margins to place these orders to
actually fulfill the things that they
were putting in place
so it's entirely possible that robin
hood had legitimate business
justifications for
limiting the trading in the way that it
did though just because robin hood might
have had some legitimate business
reasons for undertaking these practices
you can absolutely understand why users
of robin hood were
furious that robin hood prevented them
from buying more shares of gamestop
while
only allowing people to sell their
positions in gamestop which
apparently resulted in the price of
gamestop plummeting and at the same time
there were even isolated reports of
individual users who said that robinhood
literally sold the stock that they had
purchased in
gamestop though i have to believe that
in those particular cases
those users were trading on margin and
were probably facing a margin call where
in order to meet the reserve
requirements for their margin account
the brokerage sells stock to meet that
reserve requirement that's
fairly common when people are trading on
margin and i'd be surprised
if robin hood sold people's positions
who weren't subject to a margin call but
the bottom line is that users of robin
hood are absolutely furious
often for a perfectly legitimate reason
and so
because this is america they did what
americans do and they
almost immediately sued robin hood the
first lawsuit filed by robin hood user
brendan nelson
in the southern district of new york the
sdny alleges that robin hood engaged in
unlawful market manipulation by removing
gamestop stock
from its platform and nelson seeks to
make his
suit a class action and there's another
lawsuit filed in the northern district
of illinois by robin hood user richard
joseph gatz
and says that robin hood protected
institutional investment at the expense
of its retail customers the
traders the wall street bets traders
gats
alleges that this sudden halt uh
resulted in major losses because prices
were decreasing and
gats couldn't make any moves so gatsas
represented himself
and it seemed like immediately after
robin hood started doing this people
started clamoring for
a class-action lawsuit and many people
asked can robin hood be allowed to screw
over its user base in this way well i
hate to be the bearer of bad news but
it's very likely that these lawsuits are
going to be dead on arrival for a couple
of different reasons number one
when you sign up for a robin hood
account you are
forced to sign up for their terms and
conditions
to trade on robin hood you have to sign
their customer agreement regardless
of whether you don't read it this is
generally an enforceable contract
so the first question is what did all of
the users agree to and one of the very
first things that you'll see
which is very very bad news for someone
trying to file a class action lawsuit
is that everyone under section 38 of the
user agreement
agreed to arbitration and agreed to
forego
a class action suit arbitration as you
probably know is a form of
alternative dispute resolution for
resolving disputes out of court
now arbitration is often seen as a
boogeyman within legal
circles people think that arbitration
just means a plaintiff will
never get anything and that's that's
simply not true it just means that
things will be adjudicated in front of
an arbitrator instead of a court
but an arbitrator has the ability to
fashion almost any remedy so
theoretically you can get exactly the
same remedy that you can get in a
courtroom
in an arbitration they have the power to
do so and the big issue here is that the
arbitration
clause includes a class action waiver
which means that you're not
going to be able to have a class action
represent
all of the users of robinhood even if
you were able to meet
all of the requirements for a class
action under rule 23
which i am very very skeptical that
a plaintiff's lawyer would be able to
meet the requirements
that you need to have a class action in
the first place
though at the same time that can be both
a sword and a shield we've seen many
times where a company has
included a class action waiver thinking
that by breaking up every individual
plaintiff into their own arbitration
case
that's that's actually in their favor
except that when thousands of
individuals take them up on that and
have the company pay
for the arbitration that's going on the
company
can get really screwed because they'll
end up paying a huge amount of money
just to go forward in arbitration so
sometimes arbitrations are good
sometimes they're bad they're
just a tool but in this particular case
it's going to result
almost certainly in the dismissal of the
class action suit that was filed against
robin hood
but then we get to the even more
fundamental issue here which is what the
user agreement allows robin hood to do
even if plaintiffs could get around the
arbitration clause
their arguments would probably be doomed
by the other provisions
of the contract that all the users
signed for example the agreement allows
robinhood to take into account
market volatility section 13 market
volatility market orders limit orders
and queued orders i understand
that during periods of high volume
illiquidity fast movement or volatility
in the marketplace
the execution price received may differ
from the quote provided on entry of an
order
i may receive partial executions of an
order at different prices
of course robinhood reserves the right
to restrict trading or prohibit it all
together
section 16 restrictions on trading i
understand that robin hood may in its
discretion prohibit or restrict the
trading of securities
or the substitution of securities in any
of my accounts
i understand the robinhood may at any
time at its old discretion and without
prior notice to me
one prohibit or restrict my access to
use the app or the website or related
services and my ability to trade
two refuse to accept any of my
transactions three refuse to execute any
of my transactions or four
terminate my account now that says
nothing about whether this was a good
business decision
or not people are rightfully upset
people are
furious with the decisions that
robinhood has made regardless of whether
robinson had to do it whether it's
colluding with
the hedge funds or not people are
probably going to leave
robin hood on mass because they hate the
way that they have been treated
this is only to say that the user
agreement that robin hood wrote and made
all of its customers signed appears to
give them
a lot of leeway and i would not be
surprised if these
lawsuits fail simply because the
customers agreed to it in advance
but if you don't like it you can do
business with somebody else and maybe
that's a good idea
as matt levine who is absolutely the
best financial writer writing today put
it
also i have to say that if robin hood
stops letting people gamble on meme
stocks
that is going to hurt its ability to
attract customers who want to gamble
on meme stocks i simply couldn't have
said it better myself
just because it's legal doesn't mean you
have to like it
but if you want to gamble on meme stonks
you're going to need a cell phone to
mess with the app and the best cell
provider is ting mobile i personally
switched
to ting mobile why because of this yes
this is an
actual bill that i actually got and i
switched
and it's great because ting mobile has
three brand new plans to make sure that
that
never happens to you you can get talking
text for just ten dollars a month and
pay for the data you use get five
gigabytes for 25 dollars a month
and even unlimited for just 45 dollars
per month and switching plans is
actually really really easy because you
can keep your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone and the
service is great too because ting
partners with several
massive networks very possibly the exact
same network that you're using right now
but
at a huge discount now contractually i
can't tell you which ones they partner
with because i always respect contracts
but i'll give you a hint my service
hasn't changed at all
now i've been on the phone with my last
provider for hours
on just the simplest things but you can
transfer services ting by ordering a
ting sim card popping it in and setting
it up
no phone call to your old legacy carrier
at all required it's like magic and if
you're around wi-fi all the time like
you're working from home
ting still gives you their flex plan
which gives you the option to just pay
for what you use
it is a smarter cheaper version of the
same plan that they've always had
now they're just adding unlimited
versions as well so if you want
unlimited data
go crazy if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com or click on the link
in the description
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save and
legal eagles will get a 25 service
credit that could
cover months of service so just click on
the link in the description to give it a
try
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews where
i talk about all the crazy stuff that's
happening in the legal world today
so click on this playlist and i'll see
you in court